in eastern ukraine it is now a battle of
artillery
up until now ukraine unable to hit some
of the russian artillery systems that
are causing this damage because they are
too far away
that is why they asked the u.s for
long-range artillery systems and now the
biden administration has decided to give
them medium range instead helping
ukraine while trying not to provoke
moscow specifically with regard to
weapons systems being provided
the ukrainians have given us assurances
that they will not use these systems
against targets on russian territory
there is a strong trust bond between
ukraine and the united states as well as
with our allies and partners
but when it comes to these critical
weapons the u.s says it will provide
only four systems and won't say how many
gps guided rockets even though it's
reportedly only a few dozen
and it'll take at least three weeks to
train the ukrainian forces on how to use
them some military experts say the new
weapons will still have an impact so
once you have those systems the range
and precision they offer
i think open up a lot of different
battlefield options for the ukrainians
to do things like
destroy
command and control posts that are
further back from the front to destroy
logistics logistics and supply
chains for the russians
that allow them to keep advancing the
highmar system can fire six gps guided
rockets at a distance of around 70
kilometers and can be reloaded in about
a minute it's on wheels so it can
quickly move after firing
other experts say this should have
happened long ago
those triple seven should have been
there months and months ago for example
and these highmars as well so the
administration is following its own
pattern they should actually announce
that they're going to deliver
the longer range systems
the capabilities
as soon as possible
but the biden administration is clearly
concerned about provoking russia and the
russians did react
these risks certainly exist the things
that the kiev regime unapologetically
demands from its western patrons firstly
overstep all bounds of decency and
diplomatic relations and secondly our
direct provocation aimed at drawing the
west into combat
president joe biden penned an op-ed this
week to say he's adamant u.s troops will
not be in the fight but he has decided
to give ukraine the most sophisticated
weapons yet
hoping it may be enough to prevent
future russian successes on the
battlefield
patty culhane al jazeera washington
so what exactly is the system the
americans have sent to ukraine the
highmars multiple launch
rocket system or
mlrs can simultaneously fire multiple
precision guided missiles
its 70 kilometer range is almost twice
that of the m777 howitzers already
provided to ukrainian forces
the longer range version of the missile
can reach targets 300 kilometers away
but that hasn't been supplied to the
ukrainians the u.s military already has
highmar units in europe nato allies
poland and romania also have them